everybody some lightness here all right
let me see what I can do all right
better it's not better well it's gonna
be have to be good enough for today it's
all right I hope everybody's doing well
as you can see I am not in the usual
spot for those who have followed me for
a while I'm actually at my parents house
give you some little bit of flood news
before I start um I hope you understand
why I'm here the we had to move from the
place where we were staying temporarily
my family and I we found out about a
month ago that we had to move because
the house where we were staying was
being was for sale and it was sold so we
had to go and we had the kind of a short
time to get to get set up and we took
took awhile to find a place where we
could go so we moved and because it
everything was done last minute I
couldn't get the internet connected at
my house we moved on Saturday so today
is Monday is that right yeah that's
right so we've moved two days ago and
everything is a little insane right now
so trying to settle into this house
trying to get everything everything
settled one of my daughters we were
homeschooling on until now and one of my
daughters my PO year-old daughter has
decided that she is going to school so
that's what we were also doing this week
trying to get her set up for school all
of that all that crazy stuff while we
were moving and on Friday I am leaving
for South Carolina to give an icon
carving workshop so I'm gonna be leaving
for almost a month usually I leave for
for three weeks plus travel I go to
Charleston to work with my my friend and
partner
Gould who's an architect and a another
cool designer so all that is happening
at the same time it's a little bit mad
so that's why I'm here and my parents
doing the Q&A with you guys from here so
first off as some of you know we reached
the channel has reached 50,000
subscribers on I think it was on Sunday
while like while I was setting things up
in my house I saw on my phone that at
that we reached 15,000 subscribers the
the videos simple has been propaganda in
the last month or so for some reason has
started to garner attention again and
was covered by different YouTube
channels like computing forever also
some of the gamergate people geeks and
gamers featured it on his channel
through a bounding into comics article
anyway so there's been some some
interest around that video and I think
that's probably why these subscribers
just shot up so through all you new
subscribers welcome to our channel and
we do this every month recently we
started doing it live again
not again we started doing it live and
I've got two moderators in the chat I've
got my buddy
Kristen Chad who has the best name in
the world and and I also have Jakob
Russell who is becoming a good friend of
mine and he's also running the Facebook
group where people talk about symbolism
and about the videos that I'm doing so
so here we go guys as you know all the
$10 all the $10 patrons ask questions in
advance so I'll go through those first
and then we'll get to whatever super
chat type things happen to happen to
come about in the chat thanks to all the
new people that have been supporting me
through patreon as well because as you
know as those who follow me on Facebook
or Twitter on social media you've seen
that I'm not both in a lot of carving
pictures these days just because things
have been so mad that it's been really
difficult to keep that up and so this
the videos and the patrons and all this
stuff has become my main source of
revenue for now it's going to change but
it's gonna take a few months so alright
hey guys here we go
so on I'm gonna start with the questions
on my website through this symbolic
WorldCom so Pat Shire asks
good evening Jonathan and he apologizes
right away he started for the sorry for
the linking submission last time I'll
try to get to the point better this time
so he says that he's been listening to
the Harry Potter audiobooks and have
been wrestling with the symbolism of
Lord Baltimore his Death Eaters and how
Harry relates and so then he kind of
tells the story of Voldemort and is
asking me to help him understand how
Voldemort relates to Harry Potter so I
have to be honest with you guys I'm not
a big fan of Harry Potter I don't
necessarily have a problem with it I I
don't not that impressed with this story
not I know Jordan Peterson is really
impressed with that story I'm not
particularly impressed with it I feel
like it has I feel like Harry at least
in the movies I saw the movies I've been
read the books the movies Harry has a
weird MarySue element to him like he
he's everybody loves him and everybody
wants to be him and everybody you know
he's kind of like this this kind of
young superstar all the time but anyways
the the idea that there's a relationship
between death and power and there's a
strangeness in that relationship is
something that I've talked about and you
can kind of understand it that there's
this link between between death and
power so Harry you could say something
like that Voldemort and Harry like
Voldemort is this I mean Voldemort just
means what does it means like flight of
deaths I mean that's what it means it so
holding word has to do with the
symbolism of death but all over Harry
Potter is related to the problem of
power power in a magical scientific
sense
we often oppose magic in science but
that's not it's not it's least in terms
of symbolism it's not the right way to
see it the idea of power in the sense of
the capacity to act on the world in that
sense both magic
and Technology are are related and so
there's a relationship between death you
know I've talked about this I give the
garments of skin the problem of the
garments of skin and power and so I
think that that's the relay that's the
the relationship that is trying to be
played out in the Harry Potter books so
Harry has a scar so a scar is a is a is
death it's like a right it's an it's a
residue of death right it's it's like a
it's a residue of healing that is not
completely healed and that has left a
mark and that mark is kind of like the
source of his pain but at the same time
maybe secretly the source of his power
so this relationship that this this
confrontation that Harry had with death
as a baby has left him you know in pain
alone orphan all these negative things
but it also seems to be the source of
his power and so that's the that's what
Harry kind of has to deal with that's
what he has to kind of figure out how to
deal with that and so you know
ultimately it leads to the you know the
death of Voldemort I guess and and so
this idea that he that he vanquished
death with death that he used the power
that death gave him the power that
Voldemort gave him to finally defeat
Voldemort himself and so you could you
can get the idea that maybe also
Voldemort is linked to Harry in the
sense that in that moment when Harry and
him had in exchange Voldemort left
something of himself in Harry something
you could say something like that and so
he kind of kind of gave something to
Harry and Harry receive this power that
is related to death and so now how do
you deal with that how do you use the
exterior powers you have you know your
power to act in the world
how do you make sure that you use that
for positive things
technology is an ambivalent thing I've
talked about this many times you
it's it's not neither good nor bad but
it it can go both ways and two more the
more power you have the more good you
can do medicine you know all the things
we get in technology but also the the
worst the more bad you can do you can
have nuclear weapons and you can have
you know a systematic murder of large
populations you can control your people
all of that is related to the power to
act on the world so I hope that answers
that question so david Flores asked what
is the symbol of the significance of
atom being put to sleep during each
creation so he this is this is an
interesting thing if you read some of
the church fathers you'll see several
church fathers will say something like
at God foreknew the fall and it's
because God foreknew the fall that he
that he separated the separated male and
female the idea that the original atom
of the original man would have been an
androgynous being that you that was
fully had the masculine and feminine
elements fully united within him he had
heaven and earth
you see I've told you that story before
about this ocean of a you know God
breathed his breath into this gathered
dust so Adam is an image of the union of
heaven and earth but then in the
creation of Eve it's like you having a
separation of heaven and earth once
again and that separation is is remedied
through marriage through family through
the the unity of the sexes in a in a
sexual union or in a marriage but
there's also is that reality of the
separation and so a lot of the church
fathers talked about this this moment of
the separation of Adam into male and
female as a as like I said something
which just preparing Adam for the fall
is falling into opposites and so you can
see it in that very imagery the idea
that Adam falls asleep is an image a
kind of foretelling of death sleep and
death in in symbolism is always
extremely linked together
so you can see that in that image Oh
Adam sleeps and in his sleep that's when
Eve is created in this little death but
it's not death really I mean we have to
be careful it's not death but it's
something akin to death it's something
which kind of points towards the future
and and the fall and that's why for
example we we have these images of
Christ at the crucifixion there are
these beautiful hymns in the church on
Holi on holding Thursday holding Friday
where it talks about how Christ on the
tree as he's being crucified you know
the the soldier Pierce's his side and
out of his side the church is born and
so there's a there's this relationship
between the creation of Eve in the
Genesis and the church coming out of the
death of Christ where Christ and flips
it all back and and replays that that
moment in Genesis but it's like a new
beginning alright so David flora says
can you tell us about the fish painting
behind you well there's no fish painting
behind me anymore because I'm you'll
never see me in that house again but
that fish painting is was it's just one
of when we moved into the house where we
were before the other videos that you
saw for the last two months the the
person who was selling the house had had
left a lot of her stuff in there and
that fish painting was a part of it so
it was not chosen but as you know
symbolism happens and as we are swimming
out of a flood the the image of the fish
is always a is a positive image in death
that is this idea of these nuggets
you know this the shiny living thing
which is hiding in in death so that's
pretty much always the symbolism of fish
in terms of especially to the
christianity so david Flores also asking
to do a symbolic interpretation of game
one in the green night I couldn't do a
video on that but definitely not gonna
do that
right
now and he said it would be interesting
if I did a series on Gilgamesh I would
really be interested in doing that I
will probably be doing that like I I
told you guys what I'm gonna be doing
from now on is every month I'm gonna put
out a video for patrons only
and it's mostly going to be
interpretation of ancient stories and so
if I do go into let's say Gilgamesh or
Gaiman and say Gaiman and the Green
Knight he'll probably be in those patron
only videos so look out for that
so EDT asks is it significant that Judas
betrayed Jesus with the kiss
the answer is it is extremely
significant but my goodness that story
that moment is really difficult to
understand I will have to be honest with
you I've been thinking about Judas Kiss
for years and I honestly do not think
that I fully grasp that moment the best
thing I can say for that is is it is a
supreme inversion right it's the supreme
inversion where you are betraying to the
Outsiders because it's the Romans you
know that are coming to get him you'll
be trained to the outsider through a
gesture of communion so you could see it
as the ultimate betrayal but I honestly
I think that there's something far
deeper in that moment something that is
really really critical and maybe because
it's so critical that's the reason why I
don't fully see through that moment but
I'll keep thinking about it keep praying
about it keep meditating on it hopefully
one day I will have a proper intuition
on that on that moment in the Bible
story so Eddy T asked why does the
worship of the soil often involve
self-mutilation and human sacrifice
see for example similes castration of
Addis the wicker man described by Caesar
in Gaul
the child sacrifice performed by
Israel's wicked kings in the Bible even
the metre is said to have part of
Penelope's shoulder and my discerning
theme there for sure there's a theme for
sure there's a theme in the I'm not sure
the things that you're that you're
mentioning are related to each other for
sure there's the the castration the
castration of Addis and there are so
many things in what you said but let's
just one of the things you could
understand in terms of the earth let's
say this the problem of if you look at
the Demeter and and the notion of the
the shoulder that was eaten you can have
this sense of that there's a
relationship between the the the flip of
in that happens in the earth that it's
related to say this but that it's
related to certain images of self of
self turning you know that there's a
relationship between let's say the flip
that happens in the earth and something
like cannibalism or something like you
know when I talk about this double this
weird double inversion that happens you
know there's something about that in the
symbolism of how the edge turns you know
that's why the imagery has to do with
self contradictory things like the
carnival like that like the the clown's
all that that we're talking about
there's something in that but it's hard
to it's hard to fully pinpoint it's hard
to fully pinpoint and also something
really subversive about that you know
and so it's dangerous to talk about it
too much the you know that's why you
have things like Saturnalia at the end
of cycles you have these weird moments
that weird kind of inversion moments at
the end of cycles um
but but for sure Christianity kind of
solved that problem you know we've
talked about this several times
Christianity solves the problem of the
end with something like communion which
is both the the let's say the right hand
and the left hand which both has the
bread and wine but also this weird
symbolism of the scandal of cannibalism
kind of joined together where it's not
it's it's not fully wonderfully other
that they're kind of joined together
that kind of solved that problem but uh
yeah so I'm afraid that I'm not going to
be able to - totally pierce that mystery
for you there Eddie this is tough stuff
to think about especially especially all
this imagery that has to do with with
human sacrifice and and cannibalism you
know I've made a few videos about that
talk about cannibalism they kind of look
into that a little bit but it's stuff
that's really difficult to to to
understand it to talk about all right
so Jacob says I've been devour articles
at Northpark SAR journal and have found
father shillin's
follow cinnamon justanna justin jános
articles as well as you're recovering
the art series very helpful and
reintegrating visual art back into my
life especially icons the notion of a
hierarchy and iconography is especially
intriguing my problem is seeing good
idea ography versus whatever else there
is I have found myself not minding a
western touch like archimandrite xenon
or Vladimir Google in crow but I'm also
very drawn to the style of Luba yet skip
just really troubling because she seems
to make oh yeah I think I think I have
seen her icons to make a giant leap into
modern styles a part of me is saying
it's not right but I can't explain why
which leads me to wonder what is right
or maybe a focus on what is not right
should come first
um iconography is very difficult to talk
about because I think that you you said
it properly there's a there's a
hierarchy which sets itself up I think
that's how we have to see it there are
no there are no canons about style there
there's nothing in the church fathers we
talk
style except for talking about the need
for icons to not did say did say not
awaken the passions in a person so the
the icons do have to have a certain
sobriety a certain aesthetic appearance
because you don't want them to to kind
of bubble up your emotions in a in an
extreme way so that can account for a
lot of the stylistic choices that icons
came to make now like I said now there's
a hierarchy and so would you whether the
way that it should be is that you should
have a basic a basic desire to integrate
your icons into a community right that's
one of the things that people people
often forget that you know if I'm trying
to communicate something to you I need
to take into account who I'm
communicating to that I need I have to
ask myself why am i doing what I'm doing
I want to integrate it into a community
and so if you push the edge too far then
at some point you you run the risk of
you run the risk of distracting the
viewer from what it is you should be
trying to do which is bringing someone
into communion with the Saints and so
you have to be careful now there is I
can't tell you what the street law is as
to where this goes awry but there's an
organic process in the church where and
you know there has to be a kind of
proportion if the the proportion is in
right that at some point things start to
break apart and we saw that in the
destruction of iconography in the
history of the icons we saw that as the
proportions started to to to fall apart
and as the western style like I said
it's like I don't you say I don't mind a
hint of Western art now that's it that
you could say something like a spice of
Western art but it's there's a
difference between that and let's say
full-on baroque Rubens you know art
where it's all flesh it's all you know
it's all moving and it has you know it
is exactly that that thing that the
father's warned us about the problem of
eliciting the passions in people so I'm
a
that I can't give you a straight answer
and that would be very wary of people
who think that they're able to give you
a straight answer you have certain icon
groups right now that that say things
like if it doesn't have this style at
this file at this side and it's not an
icon and that's just that's just the
wrong way to address it we have to see
it like you said and like I've always
said in a hierarchy which is we we have
to say that it doesn't it's it can be an
icon but it can be an icon which is
leading us into something which is a
little bit on the edge and we just have
to be aware of that and be careful for a
net for the whole of iconography not to
slip and kind of move into that
direction but there's nothing wrong per
se with innovation but there's nothing
right with innovation either there's
nothing desirable about innovation
innovation tends to happen in moments
you know of transition or just this
organic change that happens but I would
say that most iconographer is should
have a desire to be traditional even
though some of their art might not look
totally traditional they I think most I
can I should express that desire which
is the desire to be traditional is the
desire to engage and participate in the
Communion participate in the community
and if you don't have that then you know
you're just trying to titillate people
into to create innovation for innovation
you know jazz style er kind of rock and
roll types all right and so Jesse Blaney
asks hi Jonathan
so here goes I have three big
interrelated questions on nostalgia I
might not answer all of these but let's
just see what we got question number
memory and it's connected to nostalgia I
know that in one sense nostalgia acts as
refusal to let go of a memory or an
event in the past and that nostalgia
also acts as a reminder of to return
home has the term wanderlust become a
glorified pursuit of escapism living in
a dream world does homesickness the
opposite of wanderlust help us do better
understand what heaven really is my
intuition is that this is what the story
of the prodigal son symbolically trying
to communicate so I think I think here
it really does depend on words I I do
think that there is a sense of nostalgia
in the highest sense of that word which
could be a like you said a desire to
return home so we could say that we all
have in us a nostalgia for our paradise
that all of us have a nostalgia for Eden
that that is something that it did that
is that is built into the human person
in the fall now the difficulty that I
have is that a lot of nostalgia today
has is trite it is a sentimentalism and
so it's this it is this kind of weird
sentimentalism this attachment to the to
the superficial forms of the past and I
think that that's that's the dangerous I
think that's a dangerous thing actually
I always kind of joke and say say that
what I do that's a my icon carving is
tradition without nostalgia that is that
I'm not making the icons that I make the
kind of sentimental desire to preserve
the past to preserve some forms that
were there before I have a I have a I
want to take what has been handed to me
and and make it alive like I wanted to
be alive and participative and part of
the the the world whereas there's
something about nostalgia especially
kind of kind of modern nostalgia that we
find you know in people in grownups who
I mean I have a to like I was gonna say
grown-ups
who still like the things they liked as
kids you know like grown-ups who still
collect toys or whatever all that stuff
you know there's a there's a I think
that that's an empty shallow a shallow
thing so question - does Western society
glorify nostalgia if this is true is it
it is is it an undoing larger framework
so the meta-narrative I don't totally
understand me I've also been thinking
the salient big terms and how it relates
to the biblical story of Lot's wife yeah
that's a really good that's a really
really good image actually you know the
idea that Lot's wife experienced a
moment of nostalgia for something that
she probably that she shouldn't be
experiencing nostalgia for and so as she
had to leave that she had to move away
from that burning place she looked back
and remembered the wrong thing you could
say so so because my symbolic intuition
is that when she turns around and looks
back at the city the past that's being
destroyed she takes on that destructive
form or image well it's not just that
it's the I is that she is frozen right
in that sense in that image the fact
that she looks back at the past with
this nostalgic eye it means that she she
becomes a pillar or she becomes a pillar
of salt you can't she can't she becomes
frozen
and she can't move forward like you know
I mean it's like someone who breaks up
with his girlfriend and then he just
keeps living in that weird nostalgia and
then he can't move forward he can't get
into another relationship you know you
can't you can't move on with your life
the same thing would be with someone who
who let's say someone dies and then they
don't mourn but rather they just kind of
hold on and they don't they don't want
to go through the process of mourning
and then they're stuck if they can't
move forward and so I think that I think
that I mean I think like you said I
think there are some aspects of
nostalgia which are I mean maybe the
right way to say it would be that you
should be you should be nostalgic for
paradise you should be nostalgic to
return home the real home let's say the
the true home but that that desiring
capacity that we have is the same
desiring capacity that can also make us
nostalgic for all these these these uh
tripe things that we had in our past all
these things that are that are that just
give us a good feeling you know when we
engage with them or give us a kind of
its kind of sadness you know this
melancholy sadness all right so question
384 Jessie Blaney he says the third
question is about storytelling and his
strange connection to nostalgia and so
he talks about this idea of remaking
films covering songs and so so I
acknowledge all storytelling is a
retelling and passing on a meaning a
connection to a memory or idea in
storytelling if storytelling is done
clumsily is that with the effect of what
nostalgia is so nostalgia in this way
becomes a cheap ploy a magic trick akin
to the game of Chinese whispers I think
that I think that you have I think you
have a point one of the ways to maybe
understand that is to is to understand
that you know because in his comments he
talks about the fact that now people are
just remaking movies like just remaking
you know all the stuff that we like it
was they as an adult when I was a child
you know Star Wars and and Marvel comics
and all this stuff now all they're doing
is kind of rehashing these same things
over and over it's like the fuller house
my daughter watches that show my
goodness who like when I was a kid I
remember that like how is it that this
possible that this is this is going on
and I and I would I think a good way to
understand it is is to see it as because
like you said the the true story is the
real stories they can be retold over and
over because their identity forming you
know the fact of retelling the story of
Christ every year and going through the
surgical cycle the fact of of telling
the fairy tales of all these stories
that we tell over and over there these
it's an identity for
act and it's kind it's liturgically in
the sense that it's something that we
kind of go back over and over and it
creates a a pattern for our existence
and so I think what we're seeing and I
mentioned this in some videos before so
I think that what we're seeing is a
desire for liturgy a desire for a
permanent or a stable pattern and it's
being done in a very superficial way
which is Star Wars like people who live
in Star Wars or people who you know who
are totally obsessed with mangas or or
you know Marvel comics or you know who
who talk about old video games and to
have this nostalgic feeling about old
video games and all that stuff like I
think that I think that it's it's a it's
a it's a it's a superficial version it's
a superficial filling of the the deep
desire we have for a permanent or a a
let's say a very deep pattern in which
we can be embedded and participated all
right so I'm gonna keep going here Jesse
so mass are no masks our asks hello is
there a distinction between distraction
and avoidance is the sin of despondency
related to these the parable of the
talents come to mind desiring to be to
be profitable servant with what has been
given but bearing it more often than not
I think there is a distinction between
distraction and avoidance I mean there's
probably relationship between the two
you know avoidance is I mean what it is
when you know what you have to do and
you don't do it distraction is when you
let yourself be taken away from the
things you need to do and distraction is
almost like a form of forgetting
avoidance is
maybe avoidance is different because
usually when you avoid something you it
burns you you know it's like a
procrastinating you know you you have
this burning thing you need to do and
then you feel it until you avoid doing
it you kind of skirt around it but then
it's like this coal on your head where
it's this it's constantly digging into
you whereas distraction or this this
kind of letting go or you know drinking
or watching a lot of movies or whatever
you want to do to kind of to kind of not
have to think about the thing you should
be doing or the you know the direction
you should be going could be a way to
could be maybe distraction is a way to
deal with avoidance a way to kind of
ease the suffering of avoidance for a
little while all right all right so
Keenan Cronin Keenan Cronin asks oh my
word Jonathan I feel so bad about you
having to answer these long questions
there should definitely be a word limit
yeah I'm thinking about that I'm not
gonna lose Mike and he says before you
lose your temper at us no I do think
though that guys if you're gonna write a
question you try to have to condense
because people aren't I think people
will people will get tired of reading
the long things like triadic trying to
condense your questions a little bit
just so that just so that you kind of
move through the questions and it
doesn't feel like I'm reading I'm
reading your statements on the QA and
that becomes what the community is about
all right so Keenan asks what do you
think is the right way for Christians to
evangelize in the modern world I
personally have an instinct to try and
explain the difficult parts of the Bible
to friends and family and attempt to
help them see what I see in the story is
similar to what jvp seems to do but
something tells me that this is the
wrong approach
seeing as Jesus commands us to any
thoughts on how we might approach
evangelization effectively I think I
mean I think that I think the best way
to evangelize is to become a saint
that's for sure the best way to
evangelize
- for people to see the people's to see
joy and love and meaning in your own
life that's the that's the thing that
attracts people's of most even more than
any argument you could do you know
people are attracted to - those who have
purpose and meaning and and who have a
stable foundation those who love their
neighbors all of that I think is the
right is the best way to evangelize but
I also do think that there is room for a
more let's engaged approach one of the
things that has happened in the past
hundred years or whatever is that
Christians have fallen back and back and
back and back in there because most
Christians have taken on the scientific
point of view as though let's say as
truth incarnate as you know I remember
being a Baptist and hearing people say
something like science modern science is
just the mind of God it's like wow
that's crazy
but if you want you've taken that point
then they keep they keep kind of falling
back falling back falling back losing
ground in the discussion and I do think
that there's a right now there's a
moment with the type of argue the type
of discussion that I see someone like
Drew Peterson doing just this whole
discussion about consciousness about the
return of the phenomena the
phenomenological point of view the
problem of consciousness all of these
are opportunities to now help people see
what the bible has always been about and
what christianity is really about you
know the transformative aspect of
christianity and so i think that right
now is it there's an opportunity to do
that and and hopefully that's what i'm
trying to do as well so but for sure
it's it's not that it's not the first
way to evangelize but i do think that
it's having an effect
i've seen it you know meeting more and
more people people are writing me and so
i I'm seeing that there is talking about
scripture and about Christianity in that
way and that kind of
trying to understand it as a description
of reality trying to understand it as a
description of the person in the world
and this this this experience of the
world and how it lays itself out to us I
think is is a good way to to do it right
now
so Keenan says and right after having a
go at other people for asking among
questions let me be a hypocrite and ask
another one so keen and asked what Bible
translation do you recommend for your
reading list i don't know i don't i
don't i just i just you what I tend to
do is I use like a King James Version
but right now there's so much available
resources online I forget what the name
of the website is but there's a website
you can go on and what it does it has
all the different versions of each verse
and it also has you can have a
transliterated version and so you can
read the Bible in a translation that you
find appealing I mean I like the King
James because the English is so powerful
in the King James and and then if you
want to dig in and get a sense of what's
going on then you can go online and you
can look at the different translations
and look at the transliterated and the
transliterated text to get a sense of
what what is going on that's my approach
anyways a lot of people have told me
that the the Orthodox Study Bible is
very good I don't I don't have one I
don't own a copy of it right now
and so all right so I will move on to
subscribe sorry guys here we go
alright so XRD says congrats on 50,000
subscribers it should honestly be 10
times as much well thank you so much XRD
I appreciate it I have to say that I'm
kind of I'm I'm actually kind of happy
that that the subscribers on my channel
are moving slowly because one of the
things that that I noticed is I don't
have a lot of hate Watchers and I think
the fact that I that it's not like an
explosion you know
these huge massive channels that have
you know millions of views they
especially if we're talking about
touching subjects that have to do with
human relationships a little bit of
talked about politics religion all these
difficult subjects you know if you if
your channel gets too big too fast then
you end up having a lot of hate watches
and so I would say there's a there's
crap in my comment section for sure like
like all YouTube channels but I would
say that a lot of it is pretty good and
a lot of the discussion that happens in
the comment section is it's pretty
interesting
so I tribute that to the fact that it's
like a slow organic growth alright so
John Bellinger asked my evangelical wife
believes pagan corruptions were
introduced by Constantine into the
church and Joshi will not attend the
Orthodox parish with me now I don't mean
to make you play marriage counselor but
I sense we're dealing with a fundamental
difference in worldviews the kind
described in your brothers book I was
wondering if you might have any advice
that could help me navigate the
situation and help bridge the gap once
again sorry about the weighty topic I
hope to consult the priest about this
soon um I would say I would say to be
careful because I believe marriage is a
sacred is a sacred binding and I think
that that is not only there's some
people who play tricks and I really
dislike that you see that in Catholicism
see that in the Orthodox to where they
have this idea that you know if you're
not married in the church and you can
get divorce and it doesn't count and
then you get married in the church I
think that's nonsense I think that it's
avoiding reality and treating religion
as a as a kind of as these magic tricks
that you can do I think that your
relationship your wife is it's one of
the closest things that you will ever
have to what true joining of heaven and
earth can be all the difficulties that
come with that all the good things that
come with that and so I would say to be
very careful I would say that if you
if you I would say to be careful not to
to let especially because you're already
married if you weren't married I would
say marry someone who believes the same
things at you but if you're already
married and you're changing the way that
you're believing and you're kind of
seeing things differently I would say to
be very careful not to destroy your
relationship for religious purposes and
then end and to trust God and to pray to
put that in God's hands and to say you
know what this is this is you know like
God is leading you down this path if
he's leading you towards orthodoxy you
should never doubt the transformative
effect of prayer and you should never
did you'd never doubt the fact that at
some point it might happen that you and
your wife will not have the same
religious ideas and that might be your
cross to bear you know that might be
across the bear and it might be for your
salvation you know you don't know that
so I would say to be very careful now in
terms of believing that Constantine
introduce all these pagan corruptions
into the Orthodox Church you know it's
like my goodness the the solution to
that is history like the solution to
that is history and is it's a coherent
understanding of history and a coherent
understanding of how you can't on the
one hand and I've had this problem I've
had this weird debate with a with a
Protestant pastor one time where on the
one hand he was criticizing the the
council of nicaea or he was counseling
say saying that he was criticizing thing
at the Neches for his discussion of
theosis and how the purpose of creation
was was for us to be deified and at the
same time he was upholding the decrees
of the of the church council it's like
the constantine and the the Nicene
council our Christianity is nicey and we
believe in the full divinity of the
logos and we believe that
we believe that Christ was fully defined
and if you also believe that Christ is
fully human if you look at the different
the further councils that came later
then you have to realize it our very
formulation we use words like Trinity
all these things are not in the Bible
they all came about through the the
through the history of the church and
you know the Council of Nicaea and
constand and Constantine is part of that
and and and one of the things too is is
one of the things is I think it's
important to put yourself in to help for
people need to put themselves in the
position of Christians at the time it's
like we somehow think we can abstract
that and from from here imagine that you
are the Christian Church
you've been persecuted on and off for
300 years sometimes more intensely
sometimes more subtly and you're be
praying and you're praying and you're
praying to be freed and and and for God
to deliver you from from this this
suffering that the church has been going
through and then the emperor of the
church converts to Christianity and all
of a sudden everything flips and all of
the Roman Empire within a century has
become fully Christian now you how can
you how can you how can you now standing
thousands of you know more than almost
two thousand year not less than that but
whatever like fifteen hundred years
later and and and and look back at that
and say this is when Christianity
started to fall you know it's a sad I
think it's a sad - sad misunderstanding
of sadness understanding of history and
a lot of the stuff if you look at a lot
of the stuff that people criticized
Constantine for doing was there right at
the beginning it was right there you
know the perfect example is theosis
it's like this Protestant pastor again
he was he was criticizing theosis and
saying no no no it's like this that's
not that's not
Christianity and everything in it and
it's Constantine and that's a nation and
the Council of Nicaea and I was like you
know Irenaeus talks about theosis
you know that's before the council this
this pre conciliar Christians talked
about it and so there's anyways so I'm
sorry you're having to deal with that I
I have more sympathy for you than you
can imagine
maybe I'll tell you about that at some
other point at some in some other video
alright so Christian Chad our our our
moderator
our man with the name says hi Jonathan
do you think it's possible for a society
to push the negative aspects of murder
modernity back into the margin it's hard
to see since marginalization itself is
under attack
how do we counter this excess of
openness now the thing about what your
your comment it's interesting is that
modernity is not an excess of openness
modernity is is both extremes at the
same time and that's something that is
very important to understand is just
because right now in North America we
are on the openness swing of the
pendulum does it mean that that's what
modernity is modernity is both extremes
and so modernity is both you know that
is both the extreme nationalism the kind
of Nazi type of desire to shut off an
identity and juice to you know this idea
of the absolute border between things
that's a modern thing ancient worlds
didn't have clear borders they they had
buffer zones and so this idea of the
perfect border around something whether
it's a scientific category or whether
it's a race or whether it's a nation all
of this is a modern thing now the
pendulum swing of that is in order to
break that then there's this access of
openness and this excess of mixture and
this excess of a desire to to level all
differences now both of those are are
problematic both of those are
part of the modern problem it's very
important to understand that because
would you see now and you you see let's
say extreme right-wingers who think that
somehow they're being traditional by
falling into the opposite camp and
you're not being traditional you're just
you're just you're just being modern
you're just being the opposite of the
type of modernity that is prevalent
right now in in a society but uh so can
we push I don't think so to be totally
honest with you I don't I don't think we
can do it politically and I don't think
we should do it politically I think that
so Christians second question has to do
with that and so he says have you read
anything concerning nrx our new reaction
I'm very sympathetic to the criticism of
the current system but unsure of their
solutions what do you think they get
right and wrong and I think that I agree
with you I think that I think that if
you look at the new reactionaries their
criticism of of the system is a lot of
it is right a lot of it is right on
but nrx especially like if you look at
at mahlberg there's a kind of weird the
kind of weird snobbery like this weird
era Socratic arrogance in his in his
approach and you know this this this
idea you know that okay so let me let me
let me phrase it this way now the
ultimate Christian image is that there's
nothing wrong with an elite there's
nothing wrong with an intellectual elite
there's nothing wrong I even think with
the social elite but the Christian image
of that is that the elite is supposed to
love those that are lower on the
hierarchy right and so it's it it never
didn't necessarily always play out that
way but the idea that the air is to
crack loves his serfs he's like a father
to them he takes care of them he takes
care of their needs they if they have
they need something they go to their to
their their their you know their
leader or you know the person above them
and there they ask for what they need
and then that person loves them like
like a father loves children and so
that's the Nats the normal relationship
between between the let's say that's a
Christian image of the heart right like
the person above loves the person below
and the person below is willing to serve
the person above but that there's a deal
which is that that's that that's the
proper deal and so you can see it play
itself out slowly in history as the
Middle Ages went on whereas like you you
had the type of chattel slavery that you
had in the Roman Empire of these slaves
that were worked to death in mines or
work to death in on agricultural fields
went away during the Middle Ages you
know the the serfs who were in some ways
where slaves had rights they were
attached to the land the aristocrats
weren't allowed to chase them away from
the land and so there was a deal that
was there between the two where it's
like you have to take care of me and I
will protect me take care of me and the
my let's say answer to that is also is
to serve you and to to to you know to
provide for you materially in terms of
work and all that so that's the proper
relationship now what I see in
especially in especially the kind of
weird elitist right-wingers today is a
is a is it is it is it kind of disdain
like an kind of disdain for the for the
for those that are below them on their
hierarchy no matter how they they
understand it or how they interpret it
and that I think is not Christian so I
don't think that I don't think that the
solution is at least now I don't think
the solution is political I think the
solution is is religious I think the
solution is you know in terms of these
in terms of let's say thinkers that have
talked about this in in the past I've
mentioned him before I don't agree with
everything he said but I I think I'm
closest to someone like
you know his solution to the problem was
to create a create a true elite but a
true spiritual intellectual elite and
that doesn't mean just learning stuff
doesn't mean just just just becoming
smart and and and savvy but it also
means becoming something becoming you
know coming closer to God be and also
being full of love for your neighbor all
of that is part of this this
transformation of the person that's what
we need what we need our Saints not I
don't think that I don't think that the
like I said the solution is political
it's funny because I with the nrx people
and and and these types of neural
reactionary I really always dislike evil
right from the beginning I remember
reading some of you all his work and
really finding that there was something
off about it sometimes get interesting
information to provide in terms of
traditional stories and stuff but most
the time there's something off about
about his tone something off about the
way he saw the world and I feel like
it's gotten it's escalated into to some
of the stuff that I see in those
movements so that's my perception of
that situation tough questions guys
alright alright so moving on the patreon
guys we're at about so we're about an
hour usually I try to go for about an
hour and a half so we should be fine to
get into the super chat as well alright
so Ryan Pinkham asks what do you think
about exorcisms my mother-in-law's
priest has performed or been at several
where crazy things have happened playing
things flying across the room voices
contortions also what's your symbolic
interpretation of them I don't have a
problem that exercise I was like I think
exorcisms are fine maybe if I can try to
explain it a little bit for people to
understand
I think that we underestimate the
capacity especially in terms of anything
that has to do with with I mean you
don't exercise someone because they
broke their leg right you exercise
someone because they are possessed by a
principality by a power that they are
possessed by something which is
controlling them and it's a spiritual
disease right and so you know the modern
the modern psychologists that say where
you go and you sit on a chair and you
talk about your problems there's this
idea that you can remove some of the
possessions with with speaking you know
with with with with talking about it and
you know and and that's the hint if you
if you believe that you know if you you
can understand that that speaking and
intelligence is related to to the
problem of powers and that authority is
related to the problem of powers you can
understand how an exorcism can work
because an exorcism is exercising
authority so imagine there's a hierarchy
of principalities different different
principalities different powers
different spirits of things that are
affecting you that are that are
disturbing you and if you possessed it
means that there's one of them there's
some elements some some some
principality which is ask too much pull
it has too much power over you that has
taken you over and you've kind of given
you've sold your soul to the devil lady
you sold your soul to this to this thing
to this demon and so now you're trapped
you're trapped by the demon right you
can understand it in terms I mean you
can understand ever anybody can
understand that every time you get into
a passion every time you give into a sin
it's a little bit of that right you know
especially trying to stop doing
something if you're trying to stop
smoking or you're trying to stop eating
too much or whatever it is you're trying
to stop to do and you and you give in
you feel that you can feel that pull and
feel that demon you know pulling at you
but there are cases where that becomes
so strong right that that a demon can
truly almost take over a person take
over the personality take over their
mind take over all of that and so I
don't it's not weird to believe that
authority could free you from that that
someone in authority like a priest and
already has spiritual authority that's
higher up in the hierarchy in terms of
where he is related to you
and who is also invoking the highest
power who's who is who is invoking
something which is above him and is and
those two things together can solve this
problem now to me that's just not a
problem that that can did that can that
that could happen you know it's it's no
it's it's no stranger to think that that
can happen then being sitting in a car
and driving as a father and having your
kids in the back and then your kids are
starting to get rowdy and slugging - to
push each other and dip into you know to
slap each other and then you just start
and you say stop and they stop that's
that's take that times 100 take that
times a thousand that's exorcism and it
works like it stops that they stop
feminine if you're if you don't have
authority of your kid they won't but if
you do then they'll stop so you know to
me that's trying to understand an
exorcism holy that helps to understand
all right all right let's go Aaron
Monroe asked what is the meaning of in
corrupt Saints as one who grew up
Protestant but is on a slow journey
towards orthodoxy this seems like a
world of mystery and on the surface the
macabre I assume there is some relation
to the curse of death yes
defeat or said curse deification and the
resurrection but it seems like a five
thousand piece jigsaw puzzle with
missing pieces
I understand I I totally understand why
you find that disturbing but I think you
already have you already had the answer
to your question and your question I
think you you have a glimpse of what it
what it's about you know it has to do
with the could call it a a a glimpse of
the resurrection you know a glimpse of
the the what the resurrection would look
like and it's not it's um it's important
to understand it not only in terms of
the actual phenomena of the of I mean
krupp saying let's say and that their
body doesn't decay it's also important
to understand it in terms of the effect
that that has and this has to do with
the relics I've told you guys talked a
little bit about reps before in some of
my Q&A s which is that the relic it's
not only that it is this piece of Saint
and that it is a hint of the
resurrection in the sense that in this
is that the body is part of their
continued interaction with the world
world and a promise of that but it's
also the fact that relics act as centers
you know that an incorrupt will draw
people to the faith will draw people to
the church I'll draw people to believe
it and so that's also part of the
mystery of the Resurrection because
Christ in his resurrection had a body
the church became his body and so the
something like a relic or an incorrupt
saint or a saint that performs miracles
in a certain place that has to do with
this promise of the resurrection because
around that saint it's like a little
body not just the actual physical
remains but the fact that there's a
there's healing there's people coming to
visit the relics all this is a like like
a fractal it's a smaller version of the
path
that you're seeing and it's a it's a
it's a promise and it's also the manner
in which you can understand what
ultimately the resurrection can be and
what a resurrected saint how they act as
the new principalities in the world how
in Christ we are we are called to rule
with him you know that the Saints are
going to rule with Christ and will be
the principles of of the total world
like sick and so watch this happened in
terms of a relic or the the incorrupt
body of a saint is to get a glimpse of
what that actually looks like you know
to see this community turning around
this alright so Ryan Tinkham also asks
how do you interpret the passages how to
interpret the passages that Christ says
he came to bring division set a man
against his brother his father daughter
and his mother etc it seems like a
tricky one um no I don't I don't if
there's nothing tricky about that the
thing about the logos is that the logos
both unites and separates that's what
the logos does right at the beginning of
the of the Bible you know that for
anything to exist it has to be separated
from potentiality and it also has to
then become one so the logos is always
separating and joining like if you call
out something if you say let there be
this right you're you're pulling it out
you're cutting it separating and you're
you're making it one so those two things
are always happening at the same time
the logos is always doing notes at the
same time and so there are some times in
the scripture where Christ as he's
talking or his actions tend to emphasize
one side or the other you know and so I
mean Christ talks about a good versus
when he talks about how he said he came
for the rising and falling of man
that his Christ is both the capstone and
that the tripping stone you know the
stumbling stone that that those are
those are the two things that Christ
does I feel he can bring you up to the
highest but he he will also make you
stumble because he has both of those in
him you know so so it's not it's not
weird it's difficult because we really
want Jesus to just be the nice guy that
loves everybody
but that Christ is the divine logos the
Incarnate logos and so his love is both
you know it's a consuming fire but it's
also a dividing fire it's it's both at
the same time so it can do both
hopefully it gives you a little bit of
sense of that all right how everything
is fine in the chat guys because I am
because my screen and this laptop so
small I'm struggling to be able to see
questions and the chat the same time so
hopefully everything's okay but I trust
I trust Jacobin and Christian chat
alright so here we go so drew McMann
asked hi Jonathan did you get a chance
to watch Matt Dillahunty jir debate if
so what were your thoughts how important
should apologetics and should one be
striving to coherently justified to
believe in God or is that really
presuppose and ultimately rational
justification a circular endeavor i J J
sent me the link to the debate and I
started to watch it I think I watched
maybe like the first 45 minutes but
since since like I said since I moved
and now I don't even have the internet
at home I'm not watching any YouTube
videos so I have not finished the debate
um I think that I think that I think
that there are different people have
different roles and the role that I have
or the role that I'm playing is not the
same that role that J is playing and I
and I think that you know I think we
don't we can't reduce everything to one
thing and so you know I appreciate that
Jay is able to engage with atheists you
know I have seen every event I go to now
how we totally honestly guys every event
I go to now I meet people who tell me
that they they're becoming Orthodox that
they're coming to Christianity that
they're moving in that direction and
usually they'll tell me that it's mix of
my videos and Jay Diaries videos and so
it's like I can see that it's working
like I can see that he's having an
effect on people he's shaking them up
he's he's surprising them and so and so
I think that's great
you know but like I said I I don't have
the same approach that he does and I
don't I I wouldn't I would never do that
like I would never have a debate on the
existence of God because that's not I I
don't argue with people you probably
notice this I never I don't argue with
people I just I'd rather tried to show
and show the you know show the pattern
show the beauty show the surprise people
with something they haven't thought
about in terms of not to convince them
but to just to kind of get that little
spark to hit that spark you know when
someone opens up the rival but that's
not for everybody you know some people
really are convinced by arguments and so
I think I think I wish him all the best
in what he's doing
all right so mark Peters asks hello
Jonathan I've heard you mention you sell
how much has he shaped your
understanding of biblical symbolism
without being a herself Carla it seems
that his being in the world is related
to minds to the minds are ancient of
meaning through experience and the way
by which that same meaning is
transfigured by and through the written
word so when you and Metsu say that the
symbolic language in Genesis is not
really derivative but it is the
presentation of the thing itself to us
there still seems to be an intermediate
step in how we understand mountain and
garden the step appears to be a
stripping away of what are otherwise
symbolic attributions and when a
straight sign dictates our behavior or
even that particular letters
and for specific sound so there is a
type of unique biblical symbolic
language no I don't think so
there is not as a unique type of
symbolic of biblical symbolic language
we have to be careful
that would you mean by but you mean by
stripping away of with our otherwise
symbolic attributions I think that may
be it you you haven't totally kind of
gotten to what what we're talking about
when we're talking about symbolism you
could say something as radical is that
symbolism is the very reason why you
perceive unity in anything the fact that
you see anything as one and you can say
that you can say that's a you know
that's a computer that's a person that's
this that is the symbolic process coming
together elements the the joining
together of multiples into one that's
the symbol and so and so the idea is a
lot of the rationalizations you know
come later and and I do think there is
an ascetic there's a maybe I get what
you're saying there is an ascetic
practice which you can do which is to
try to get to the basic elements you
could say so you know let's say you want
to try to understand what clothing is
well you you try to to find the most
basic elements that which really
constitutes clothing not in terms of
just their they're not just in terms of
their physical existence but in terms of
the why would that exist like why would
clothing exist why would we consider
that a category and so it's like human
intention human existence is in there
with the categorization the purpose of
the the the thing and so that's why
that's why say Maximus in st. Maximus
the Confessor that's why you see that
the idea of the the ideas take the
notion of the ideas in Plato but he also
joins them with the notion of purpose
and so the logos didn't say Maximus is
the essence of something but it's also
its purpose it's also its origin right
and it's also its its purpose and also
in the sense of blankets its Telos so
it's like all of that is bound up in st.
Maximus is notion of logos and so that's
I think is such a useful thing in order
to understand how this experience of the
world we have you know is full as
glowing if you can really be attentive
it's full of meaning because you can't
like I said you can you perceive the
world without without meat without
meaning now in terms of you cell I to be
honest I'm I've read more
Heidegger than yourself for some reason
I've I find Heidegger easier to to
understand some people will say yeah
whatever I figure is is really hard to
understand I don't know why I don't know
why that when I read Heidegger I have I
just understand what he's talking about
more I find that when I read if you sell
that was a long time ago now it just
just wasn't clicking for me it just I
just wasn't I could see what he was
trying to get to but I I felt like no no
no I I do prefer Heidegger all right
guys
ok so we are we are done with the
question so I'm going to now I'm going
to jump into the super chats let's get
them up here should have had them up
there already
sorry guys
in the meantime I can tell you guys that
I am going I haven't put it up yet in
terms of the in terms of my on my
website there's a there's a section
where you can find all my coming events
and so I am going to be in Chicago at
the end of October and so I'm also and
so that is up is if you guys are near
Chicago it would be great for you to
come I'm going to speak at a in a
Catholic Church
where there is a sacred arts guilt and
so I will be there alright okay so here
we go I've got the super chats in front
of me let's see all right I think this
is doable aren't I mean heard that many
all right let's do this like I said I
will not read if there are any
obscenities and stupid stuff I will just
not I'm not gonna read it
so don't waste your money if you're
gonna say if you're just gonna say
stupid stuff
alright so Michelle Alta asks for $2.99
she asks why was held created and how ah
yeah well I think we've been over this a
few times but it depends what you mean
by hell if I hell do you mean death or
if by hell you mean the river of fire if
there's a relationship kind of between
sue they're not the same the idea is
that health wasn't created in the basic
sense it's mostly that hell is that's a
death is a is a byproduct of existence
when we mean for something for
things to exist for something besides
the the infinite one of God to exist
there has to be a relationship between
multiplicity and unity and that's even
for God in Christian terms we believe in
the Holy Trinity
we believe that unity and multiplicity
that's the pattern of everything and so
death help is a byproduct of that
because if you if you move towards if
you split them apart then you get death
right if you don't have them together
don't have unity and multiplicity
together you get death right and so if
you move if you move towards the oneness
of something only then you and you you
see it also as it's a self containing
then that's pride and then you fall and
then what it gives you is death in the
sense of a breaking apart and so so it's
not that hell is created it's that it's
it's like it's the it's the risk it's
the risk of reality right it's the risk
of reality existing is the possibility
of break down where we where we fall
into idiosyncrasies and we lose the
cohesion of what we are you know and
that's what death is the in in the Bible
now in terms of the the river of fire
the lake of fire the most common at
least Orthodox understanding of it is is
to understand that it is the presence of
God itself it's the love of God which is
what's burning people in hell and I've
explained it a few times I can plane it
one last time maybe is you know if you
close yourself off if you want to live
in this idiosyncratic thing right if you
have some passion and say you you you
give in to to some anger and you you
you you live in your anger like you know
and anger gives you this energy like it
it gives you a sense if you're alive
that when you're angry you feel alive
and you throw yourself into that and
then it becomes you and it and it you
know because it makes you feel powerful
in and it gives you that sense right the
thrill and so you you attach yourself to
it and then when the infinite love of
God you you come into contact with it
that love wants to connect you to
everything else wants to say no no that
little thing that you've attached
yourself to that's not you that's not
totality you're wrong about that you're
you're deluding yourself if you think
that this is what gives you light right
but if you refuse to let go then it's
gonna burn you it's gonna burn you
because it's like you're faced with
reality and you're refusing reality you
want to hold on to your illusion but you
still have reality in your face that's
really that's like permeating you but
you refuse to let go and that's what
that's the that's the general Orthodox
understanding of of Hell hope that makes
sense
all right so Stephen Anderson asked can
you expand on the vinegar that was
offered to Christ on the cross to me it
seems like an inversion of wine but just
wondering what you made of it that's
also a really mysterious aspect that
I've been thinking about for for years
and I think that it has for sure it has
to do with death sure it has to do with
with drinking the vinegar has to do with
dying because it's not that it's an
inversion of wine it's that wine is is
is death it's like it's like a
controlled death you could say in the
sense that it's it's contained in a
process and then if it goes too far then
it becomes vinegar and so I think that
that's what it
has to do it and has to do with
bitterness as well it has to do with
drinking the ocean you could say
something like that
this idea of the lower waters in
Scripture
dad you have bitter waters you know of
the salt waters so I think that Christ's
drinking vinegar has to do with that
image as well it's like he's drinking
him he's taking this chaotic potential
his chaotic death into himself that's
the best I could do but I think there's
more to it than that but I haven't I
haven't pierced that mystery completely
so the mad truth asks wait I'm in the
wrong QA guys what is going on hope I'm
so sorry and I'm not even looking at
you're not even looking at you probably
told me already 10 times in the comments
that I'm reading the old questions I'm
reading the big July Q&A questions see
that's how my gun is don't trust me with
with this stuff
technology magnets all right I'm good
okay I am going back it'll just make
this conversation longer I'll let it go
a little longer all right till August QA
sorry here we go the mad truth I notice
because I saw the mad truth that asked
me a question of July QA and I'm like
wait a minute this is something wrong so
the mad truth asks I hope that my my
answer to the question was the same as
the one I said before I think I'm gonna
go back and listen to my old old answer
and see if I answered the same thing or
if I changed it if I changed it hmm so
the mad truth says do you believe that
Christianity more than other religions
most completely reveals the structure
and meaning of the universe and God the
answer is yes and I think that a lot of
people will be cynical about that
because I am Christian I was born
Christian and I can understand the
cynicism that you would have regarding
that um but I'm gonna make a video on
this pretty soon and I'm gonna I'm gonna
explain it more and I think I think that
right
now the good time to understand that I
think that one of the aspects there are
many aspects which makes Christianity
the highest the most powerful image of
reality one has to do with the fact that
it contains its own destruction
within itself its own destruction which
leads to a resurrection so it's like
it's almost as if Christianity has
anticipated the whole thing it's like
within its story it has a betrayal right
so Judas betrays Christ and then Christ
dies and then he resurrects and then you
have this image that this is that out of
Christianity will come Antichrist and
that Antichrist will will devour will
destroy or not completely succeed but
you know come almost to the point of
destroying Christianity and then out of
that would be another flip and it's
going to return and so I think that
that's one of the most that's really a
really really powerful image and also
because Christ contains you know all the
extremes in one person he has I've been
telling you guys about this for a few
months now you know no he's both the
king and the criminal and he has all
these extremes kind of all joined into
one story and he goes to the highest
into the Holy of Holies he descends into
the the bottom of the earth it's like he
fills up the whole world and so I don't
think there's another story like that
maybe someone can find it for me I can
look at it but I don't think there's
another story like that all right so the
mad truth again asked is it necessary
Jesus being historical person
it is not Christ's spirit in hearts
minds enough is he not that for those
who didn't meet they story purposes and
I think that it is necessary for Jesus
to be a story person because Christ
joins it all together
and so it's it can't just be a an idea
it has to have had a realization in the
world for the whole thing to come
together because that's what Christ is
Christ is the joining of all the
realities together you could say and so
because of that it also it also has to
have happened if the story of Christ
that say the story we have in the
Gospels does not refer to events that
happen in the world does not refer to a
person that was born and lived and died
and resurrected in the world then it's
not Christ it's not the fullness it
doesn't have it all right it's just it's
if you could say it's it's it's not it's
just heavenly it's just just incarnate
it's just the pattern right but it
doesn't have the fullness in in the
connection to the world it's not that
it's not that point that joins heaven
and earth together that fills and fills
the earth with heaven and that brings
the earth up into heaven as well right
this crazy image that st. Paul uses
right it's like everything is gathered
and gathered together brought in into
God right that's the theosis
that Christ accomplishes and so what you
start to understand that it's it's it's
not as bothersome - it's almost as if
people believe that there's something
demeaning about the idea that Christ is
an actual person there's something
trying about that
there's nothing trite about it because
that's the whole point that's the whole
point of all things joining together
right so I hope that that answers so so
the man truth asking what English
translation I would recommend
I answered that um all right let's see
so James David asks how do I share my
experiences with others without
disgracing the personal feminine
experience by ex locating it perhaps
things that should remain implicit are
things that are inherent good their own
ends I think that I think that you you
you really have a good question you
really have a good question
there's it there's something tricky
about that and which is you know Christ
talks about going into the secret place
he talks about the praying in the secret
place and that's true prayer you know
going to your room shut the door and and
and pray in secret now now the problem
is that so so I understand what you're
like you're asking the sense that if if
you don't talk about let's say those
experiences then you think they're not
they're not going to have an effect in
the world it's the weird thing about
about humility is the weird thing about
and I agree that it's it's it's kind of
hard to understand but that's why you
see that most Saints stories are usually
told by someone else that the only Saint
with an autobiography is Augustine for
with that with what that's worth no I I
don't want to be crying about this like
I like I like Augustine I'm not not
against Augustine but you know it is
interesting that Augustine is the
probably one of the only Saints it has a
published autobiography anyways
usually you usually sometimes what
they'll do is that they'll find some
writings of the saint and after they're
dead they'll find their fill finds
things that they've written down their
journals or whatever or or other people
will have seen them heard them talk to
them and will have gotten glimpses over
there holiness and so there is this idea
that
you have to be careful not to not to
boast of your spiritual experiences but
it's it's tricky I read with you it's
tricky I don't have I don't have a I
don't have a set a set answer for you
so Jonathan ought asked magic seems in
part to be an inversion of the
traditional means of approaching God
such as when Saul seeks a witch to make
Samuel talk from beyond the grave what
is magic your thoughts
I think magic is too broad a category in
terms of understanding this like I think
that magic you could say you could say
that one of the problems had is the
whole of modernity has really ruined our
understanding of magic or magicians or
all that stuff I think I think that
magic traditionally at least was just
the desire to use knowledge to affect
the world like - - and to understand how
language how ritual how certain
interactions can affect reality if you
look at in the Middle Ages you know the
magician's were neither good nor bad in
the Middle Ages it they they were just
there was good magic and there's bad
magic and there's like few practice good
magic it was then a big deal you know
you may be you know it's like maybe you
should pray but yeah you know what it's
like you can and if you practice bad
magic then and then you could be you
could be brought to court but it was it
was because of the effect that you were
having and so I think it's I think it's
it's it's like I said it's tricky now
there is something about magic that is
negative especially the Old Testament
the very idea of affecting the world in
the Old Testament is extremely negative
the idea that there's something fishy
about even building a city there's
something fishy about even building the
you know this idea of the altar of uncut
stone is the ultimate altar the idea of
leaving things pristine not modifying
nature you know you see that in the
whole tradition of Enoch you have this
idea that so fallen angels that taught
human beings skills by which to modify
nature and skills related to magic and
science what we call science today um so
in that sense you could understand it as
an inversion because it's it's a desire
to take control and to control us if
circumstances right - to control what's
gonna happen to us - to trust in the
material world trust in our power trust
in all that
so there's pride in that oh that but
it's not just magic it's also technology
as well so we have to be careful not to
think that magic because it's old and
because it's we it doesn't it doesn't
fit with the way we understand the world
in somehow evil but that technology is
fine it's like there's something tricky
about affecting of our desire to want to
control to affect to to stabilize the
world right and have absolute control
right now in terms of necromancy which
is what you're referring to that's a
whole other question you know this idea
of making residues speak making
capturing the residues of something and
I'm using it to have power I think that
that's that's a whole other thing and
it's also probably the most dangerous
type of magic you could say in the sense
that you know you there is power and
there's power in depth talk I've talked
to you guys about this there's power
hidden in the residues of things how can
I explain this in a way that you guys
will understand and
think I'm absolutely crazy all right a
good way to understand it is this has to
do also with divinization right most
divinization is creating a kind of
chaotic thing right mixing a bowl or
throwing some stones or throwing some
throwing lots right so casting Lots and
then and then looking into the lots you
know having a deck of cards of tarot
cards and them coming out by chance and
then now gathering that into a pattern
okay and and in a certain way you could
almost say that project into the pattern
so a good way to understand in romancey
is having is is very powerful today is
archeology archeology is a form of
necromancy and so you you dig into the
ground and you find these things that
are disconnected from memory that are
forgotten that have no participative
life anymore
and then you use these things to
interpret the world with and so if you a
great example of one of the greatest
examples was was like the Egyptology
madness that came about you know in the
time of the Enlightenment where you know
people like Newton and all these people
were obsessed with Egypt because they
couldn't read the language and so it was
this dead thing completely dead there
was no connection then the connection
was severed between heaven and earth
there there was just these residues of a
civilization and then they use that they
dug into the ground they found these
statues he's heartless all these things
and then they use that
to destroy to try to destroy
Christianity they used it to to try to
they projected into it all their
passions all their ideas all they wanted
it to be and then they they used it to
try to have an effect on the world and
so that's a that's a form of necromancy
and it's very dangerous because what
you're capturing are these dead residues
and so the pattern is something that you
like I said you end up projecting into
it and can be very powerful you know
that's why you know that's why a lot of
the the you know they find some random
bit of text in the desert in Egypt
that's like three lines and and then a
scholar will declare that they have
debunked all of the Christian history
because they found this random piece of
of text in the desert you know and it's
still happening today it's continually
continually having every Easter every
Easter around the time of user you know
we have some discovery that some Archaea
archaeologists made that is going to
disprove to us Christianity you know
it's just necromancy so don't get don't
be convinced by that stuff all right so
Gabriel are asked why do you struggle
with taking a stand for or against
Darwinism it's very odd as it's not
trivial matter for the Orthodox well
Gabriel when you say it's not a trivial
matter for the Orthodox I'm not sure who
you're talking about I'm sure it's not a
trivial matter for some Orthodox and I'm
sure it's a trivial matter for for some
Orthodox for this Orthodox I find it to
be a trivial matter I don't I don't
I don't feel like it is a useful I don't
feel like it's a useful place to fight
you know I I just don't I just don't see
I think the danger of believing in
scientism as being the first manner in
which reality is understood is far more
dangerous than Darwin specifically and
my tendency to let's say ignore Darwin
has to do with my tendency to understand
our experience in the world has been
more primordial than a technical
description of how how animals reproduce
or how their genes you know so and I
think that I think that I don't even
understand like take a stand against
Darwin I don't understand it's like a
lot of the stuff that Darwin described
is is perfectly fine the sense of the
sense of of how of how selection happens
and how different mates select different
mates and how it encourages encourages
different aspects of different animals
like for my goodness sake like people
have been doing it to dogs for 10,000
years that's why we have all these
different these different species of
dogs because the process that he
describes is was was was pretty good in
terms of terms of understanding how this
happens now whether or not Darwin thinks
that he can create a narrative out of
that I mean I don't I don't attach
myself to that narrative at all like
that story is I find is not useful in
terms of our existent I find that the
story in the Bible the way that they
describe this this coming into
consciousness and then you know this
this relationship between
language word and how the world comes
about through language and speaking the
world in to be how you know how a
certain form of consciousness the
opening of the eyes and the seeing of
the two opposites of good and evil will
lead to fragmentation into a fault like
to me that it's far more useful to
living in the world and anything Darwin
could ever have said to me Darwin is
like a little footnote in reality and so
I don't feel like I need to take a stand
against Darwinism any more than to me
it's just not important so I'm sorry I
mean whatever like I you know anyways
that's all I can say guys like I just I
just don't find it I just don't find it
that important I don't find that that's
where my my battle needs to be and I
find creationists silly like the the the
the kind of sign the the type of
creationist that has fully taken the
scientism pill and is trying to
force-feed that pill into the book of
Genesis I find I find that far more
disgusting and far more unbearable than
anything that target said because at
least Darwin wasn't talking about the
Bible
these Darin wasn't wasn't trying to get
us to think that the those beautiful
amazing stories that we have in Genesis
were limited to some technical you know
some technical scientific description of
the world sorry guys now you're gonna
give me into rant mode here guys
alright so drew McMahon asked to clarify
my question about apologetics I was not
necessarily asked if you personally
would debate the way Jay does but rather
if one can have a fully rational
justification for God or if it's
presuppose alright I understand you know
I don't think that I don't think that
you can have a fully rational
justification I do believe that reason
properly engaged has within itself the
capacity to also show its limits and and
so so I believe that through reason we
can we can see the limits of reason and
we can see how it points to something
which transcends it or something which
is beyond it you know like I think that
your thoughts can point you towards the
noose but they can never reach there
it's like there's a there's a there's a
cut off and then at some point there's
something beyond it and so I think that
so I think that I don't think that it's
useless to engage in reasonable
discussion about God I think that's
silly to say that but I don't think that
we can I don't think that in reason is
where we encounter the fullness of of
God at night and and and I would be
surprised if if for example Jay thinks
that you know I don't think probably Jay
doesn't think that because if you're
meeting Gregory Palamas you read Saints
angry you know saying max what's in
fester they talk about God this
encounter with God as a as a you know as
a as an experience right as a as a
participative act as a participative
reality not as a as a reasonably
rational argument but like I said I
don't think it's useless but so
hopefully that answers the question guys
all right all right guys so I hope that
I hope that the the chat was not too
crazy I have to get I'll have to uh let
me reload that let me just reload the
the chat see if new things came up
reload the super chat
so hopefully with with too crazy I'll
try to get a sense from Drew from from
Christian and from Jacob how it went
later
I'll probably go through some of your
some of your comments when I log off and
then next month I will hopefully have a
bigger screen and I'll be able to follow
the be able to follow the chats also
while they're going on a little bit
while I'm talking it's something I find
hard to do I I really am impressed by
the youtubers who are somehow able to
coherently speak and at the same time
like follow the superjet all right let
me see it's not loading come on guys
come on
all right for some reason that super
Jets won't load up again sorry guys
alright so let me see come on come on so
if it doesn't load what I'll do is I'll
just I'll either try to answer in the
end the chat through text or next month
I'll try to get to those some reason it
is not loading I don't know why YouTube
doesn't want to give me the gate doesn't
want to give me the chance
alright let me just scroll up this way
now alright guys I think I think I think
I think I got I got most of them sorry
no all right so I'm seeing some stuff
alright all dirt I I think I met I
missed some questions because oh I know
which question I miss by the way let me
get back to that in two seconds
all right so there was someone who'd
send me a question let's see here we go
this is where you are seriously seeing
my my problems with my problems with
technology all right okay who go ah yeah
sorry guys I'm not ready for this I took
Laura Laura Giles asked a question
because she couldn't for some reason she
could for some reason get get okay here
we go
I can't find her question that's
horrible all right Laura if you're
watching this I am sorry I will get your
question next month and let's see let me
say on the chat right so Christian says
you might have missed a patreon question
from Robert Smits Robert Smith alright
okay see here we go Robert Smith's as
what are the symbolic differences if any
between waters from above rain waters at
earth level and waters that come from
below Springs aquifers
well waters all right so one of the
important things to understand I think
I've kind of answered that before a
little bit I think that the most
important thing to understand about
water is that water always flows down
and so no matter where it comes from
like it it tends to always come calm
down and so that's why waters are seen
as it has kind of the influence of
heaven you could say that's why you have
a separation of waters above and below
in in Scripture so you have this this
upper potentiality you could call it and
it's this lower potentiality so the
upper potentiality is the spiritual
influence that comes down from heaven
and then the the lower water the salt
waters are this kind of chaotic
potentiality that's at the bottom of the
world right and so what what's important
is understanding how those ultimately
come from the same place you know that's
the non-duality of Christianity which
which a lot of people struggle to
understand but uh so when you talk about
rain the water that comes from above is
always freshwater it falls so all the
water that comes from above is always
fresh whether it's a river that comes
down whether it's water the rain that
comes down it's running it's living
water you know Christ talks about live
water so it's this river that comes down
and then the water that's below so the
water bug is is a masculine image right
Christ talks about that in his encounter
with the UH Samaritan woman a Samaritan
woman where he he talks about living
water that he'll give her living water
and she offers him well water with water
from below is stable water right and so
that's the kind of the way to understand
it like the water that is coming down is
water is masculine and the water that is
below is feminine and in terms of the
water below you have two types of waters
you have bitter waters and you have
fresh water or water that can be that
you can drink and so the the the bitter
waters are that say the two assets of
the lower waters we talked about this
before it's like one is chaos when it's
potential and they're that they're kind
of they come from the same place but one
is potentiality is how it's related to
heaven and I would can be joined with
heaven and that's a chaos is how it's
not going with heaven something like
that and so that's that's how you can
understand the relationship between the
the waters above and and the waters
below all right hopefully that does it
for that alright guys sorry this is so
chaotic all right let me and I'm really
annoyed that I can't find this question
she wrote me okay I think I've got it
sorry guys
this is a Susan doing well it's not
doing well alright
all right so that's not gonna happen so
let's see if let's just let me see once
again if there are questions in the chat
that I missed I thanks for you a lot of
you guys are sending some of you guys
are sending super chats not actually
asking a question so that's that's very
kind of you I appreciate it all right
guys so I think I think we've come to
the end of this sorry that you got a
little bit crazy at the end a little bit
chaotic once again guys I appreciate you
coming in on this we had we had more
people than usual to I think we reached
up to like 170 so that's pretty cool and
I will I'm gonna like I said I'm leaving
in a week
to the US I'm gonna be in South Carolina
almost like for a month but probably I
will actually so I'm saying that next
time we'll be fine
I'll probably be doing my next Q&A from
the US and so I still have this little
this little laptop and and it might be I
might have the same problem so sorry
guys do what we can here so with thanks
again guys wits and once again and I
will see you in a month